this man strolling casually through a
market in taiwan's Taipei shared on the
platform X is no ordinary man he is one
of the richest people in the world
Jensen Huang is the CEO of Nvidia which
is worth more than meta Tesla and is
catching up to Amazon in alphabet shares
of Nvidia have soared this year bringing
the company's valuation to one trillion
dollars it's one of only a handful of
publicly traded companies valued at a
trillion dollars or more Nvidia is a
chip maker that has gone from powering
gaming to powering AI systems it's the
brainchild of Jensen Wong who studied
electrical engineering at Oregon State
in Stanford before founding Nvidia in
1993 with two friends the three
Engineers sealed the deal at a Denny's
where Jensen waited tables as a student
which helped pull him out of his shell I
remember calling my mom and telling her
that I'm going to start this company and
she says you know what did you what do
you guys do and I said we built these
things called 3D Graphics chips and and
people would use them to play games
and and then she she said why don't you
go get a job
he had a different perspective from his
mom Jensen grew up at the start of the
video game era and understood how big
the gaming industry could get our Common
Sense was unique
nobody would have created the technology
nobody would have created a company with
a sole purpose of Building Technology to
make video games possible
[Music]
idea focused on building powerful
Graphics processing units gpus to make
video game Graphics appear more smooth
and realistic when Nvidia went public in
1999 with Jensen owning 3.6 of the
company video games became its primary
growth driver and then Hollywood Came
Calling using Nvidia graphics for making
movies in hospitals for medical imaging
with its success Nvidia was living up to
its Latin name Nvidia meaning Envy the
founders had considered names containing
NV as they had a habit of labeling their
project files next version Nvidia became
the Envy of the tech World in a fiercely
competitive market dozens of 3D Graphics
companies started popping up in Silicon
Valley and soon hundreds so how did
Nvidia manage to pull ahead of the
competition exceptional CEOs are
constantly striving to improve they
appreciate the impact of Moore's Law
which predicts a doubling of computing
power roughly every two years due to the
ability to fit ever smaller transition
sisters onto microchips for Jensen this
principle encapsulates the need for
continuous innovation he realized that
3D Graphics could be used for a lot more
than video games for example Nvidia
invested in a struggling company called
Keyhole which had created a remarkable
3D virtual world you could start out in
space type in any address and be
transported there immediately right down
to street level where you could view
buildings and houses Google eventually
bought that company and rebranded it as
Google Earth Jensen's fascination with
3D mapping the Earth could perhaps be
traced to his International upbringing
born in Taiwan and raised in Thailand
civil unrest forces parents to send him
and his brother to the U.S where his
aunt and uncle who were already in the
states arranged for him to attend what
they believed was a boarding school in
Kentucky it was actually a Christian
reform school intended for juveniles
with behavioral problems despite its
tough environment where kids carried
pocket knives Jensen grew resilient and
ultimately appreciated his time there
his parents eventually arrived in
America and they settled as a family
outside of Portland Oregon while
studying at Oregon State Jensen fell in
love not only with engineering but with
his lab partner Lori who became his life
partner they married and had two
children both of whom now work at Nvidia
Jensen recognized that for NVIDIA to
stay ahead of the curve it had to expand
the use of its technology Beyond gaming
and Google Earth Nvidia made the
Strategic decision to program its gpus
to fuel deep learning a branch of
artificial intelligence that mimics the
human brain's ability to recognize
patterns and process data much more
quickly and accurately than a human can
Nvidia allocated billions of dollars to
develop more powerful chips capable of
supporting artificial intelligence
applications ladies and gentlemen
the world's largest graphics card Nvidia
quickly dominated the AI space
reportedly capturing 95 of the market
for graphics processors used for machine
learning all the big tech companies rely
on Nvidia in their data centers like
Amazon's AWS Elon Musk recently
highlighted the critical role of
nvidia's Technology empowering Tesla's
self-driving software we'll actually
take the video hard risk as fast as a
video will deliver to us tremendous
respect for Jensen and Nvidia they've
done an incredible job however Nvidia
has struggled to supply all the a100
chips Tesla needs because it has so many
customers and with demand for Tesla's
increasing the electric car company is
investing over a billion dollars to
build its own AI supercomputer dubbed
dojo and frankly I don't know if they
could deliver us enough gpus we might
not need to don't know what they can't
nvidia's Cutting Edge ship is so
precious that Washington has banned the
export of the a100 and its successor of
the h100 to China Hong Kong and Russia
at a fear could be used by their Armed
Forces despite nvidia's utter dominance
Jensen isn't slowing down he wants
Nvidia to make the training of AI models
over 1 million percent faster than it
currently is
much like the gpus he pioneered Jensen
huang's story isn't about numbers or
performance metrics it's about the
Relentless pursuit of progress and the
courage to steer a company in a New
Direction when there is an untapped
opportunity and when it comes to
untapped opportunities there are perhaps
none greater than an AI
you can foster Jensen's love for
Learning and problem solving with
brilliant a website and app where you
can learn math data science in computer
science interactively you can explore
the world of artificial intelligence
with Brilliance introduction to neural
networks course where you'll gain an
understanding of how AI brains operate
and learn brilliant is part of my daily
routine I like to dive into their logic
puzzles which are a fun challenge
there's something for everyone from
beginners to Advanced Learners of stem
you can start with a free 30-day trial
of brilliant by signing up with my
custom link in the description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people to sign up through my link will
receive a 20 discount on brillian's
premium annual subscription unlocking
all of the courses thanks for watching
for newsthink I'm Cindy Palm